I thought that it was just gonna be you
and me and he'll tell you I was like oh
you're here today I thought was just hey
wait a minute no I know I'm an either
when you show that was I think your
phone up and text somebody no good
[ __ ] sport oh man that's not quiet as
a dermatologist I have a point of view
on [ __ ] basketball and I your fault I
disagree with what you guys are saying
and and also is you guys are forgetting
about the south and it's also cool
because um hey man that's my wallet give
him that if you pay for the SAT scores
oh hey Chris don't be stale you're on
the podcast right now don't be a dick
don't say so don't do that
listen I want to ask you a question I
were looking at your Wikipedia page I'm
here with Eric Griffin I'm with Brendan
Schaub yeah yeah I know you know those
guys okay do I turn into a racer
Andrew what's up bro what's up Andrew
Santino hey Brian what the hell dude no
okay I was in Africa take it easy
awesome yeah dude I saw I saw it it take
it easy
I just comes there like it feels
entourage what get them out of my chair
crazy dude this is my podcast now you
can't just take over the podcast for the
Rat King the bee sting in the red rocket
you're [ __ ] out
rocket and the piece tonight you come
now revolution has begun Jesus Christ
you guys are fighting this is a mutiny
tonight hey guys hey guys what's
building yeah kill him okay hey hey say
goodbye a box you guys say goodbye say
goodbye to your fans cuz it's over the
time has come say goodbye to your fans
it's over been voted off the island
you've been voted off bro
this is survived survivor podcast I'm
just old yeah is this new blood in the
old blood right hold my gun man I know
we saw Brian live so is he yawning is
that what he's doing there so not cool
just trying to get you a Rolex but what
am i what are you doing it's a black
dude you're doing hi I'm successful and
so is he not so much hey what the [ __ ]
cha just saying this is my place you're
showing up a news clip wearing my
sweatshirt you're trying to promote your
brand with my just workout news that's
cashmere sweater yes that's a [ __ ]
Russell Athletic so got the from dick
take it back - I'm not taking it back
right now got it
you can't even fix that in the color
code what are you trying to adjust the
color [ __ ] gray [ __ ] you [ __ ] great spot
great tix brings out my eyes you don't
have eyes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]
shut up Brian will you finally sick of a
[ __ ]
well well kind of will be yeah see what
I said to [ __ ] Chris D'Elia Oh serious
man yeah
who who's that
listen if you're feeling froggy you got
a head and leap all right now you look
at the trouble can you be in disrespect
downing water table hey trouble here
okay drop here no no no why don't you go
get me a [ __ ] almond milk lot yeah
yeah you man good for nothing me until
you guys are making me up bein a male
right now I'm into sports
okay I know Stefan car Steph Curry went
off gold stayed off see the it's almost
unfair you arch your back like a
Chiquita banana hey Jamie yeah a [ __ ]
disrespect you let that one go on your
own pie I'm gonna let that one go now I
don't let that you came up real close to
my face I'm gonna let that go and I'm
gonna describe all right bro guide your
wrist pin and [ __ ] off smacked you do it
one more [ __ ] time know what I'm
coming at you do me a favor if you
decide to step into that ring and I'm
being dead serious let's go I'm being
dead seal of z' make sure no Bluffs make
sure gloves no gloves I'm we're talking
about a street fight
make sure well you set a ring right make
sure you if you step over the line
we got gloves all right well if somebody
if we happen to cross a ring in
straightest is the Alzheimer's kick and
then do you see that your meds today
you're all over bro - yeah that's all I
take yeah pro-peace I told my hair the
hair stuff yeah but nothing else
you don't take something for your pee no
I don't and I don't need anything for my
peepee look at that ever taken viagra I
bet you take pee-pee pills
I don't you take peepee hair and you
take calcium pills I don't take calcium
pills yeah because your bones
pronto my bum
my bones look that I've seen them what's
the density of your bones like titanium
titanium yeah like titanium bones
they're stupid don't worry
let's job hit you as hard as you can in
your thigh you could hit me anywhere he
wants okay but just know this know this
if you guys if you want to street fight
with me yeah pack a [ __ ] lunch bro
I'd say package you're gonna be there
why gonna fight all day if they got DNA
in 30 years what are they gonna have
besides DNA are they gonna be able to
tap into your brain and and get a map of
your brain dude you know what they're
gonna have which is horrifying is your
old headshots Nick it's not that bird
it's not that much of a bird mm it's not
it's not that much of a burn stop
covering them oh my god it's not that
big of a bird it's not that bad oh
that's so obnoxious oh all right
those all right who got me a little bit
you didn't get me a lot ah you are gonna
have you're gonna hear here's a picture
right here you see the bottom right ages
at the red eyes [ __ ] oh the red eyes
hey that one right there that's more
like oh my god Oh optical cavity is a
[ __ ] oh that's me oh man that's that
[Laughter]
keep that I can't talk I don't I sound
like when I drop when I when I [ __ ] dust
[ __ ] a little twist ACMA and the spy
how about little cookies potty owl a
little crooked teeth but I don't has a
ring for little crooked teeth I don't
have crooked teeth yo yo yo a little
crooked teeth I said I don't have to
cook my you know like that no there's
RIT that kind of they're not crooked
enough that the Invisalign work so let's
call it worked
Oh
wrinkle twist a little wrinkled face
it's not a wrinkled face up in here
y'all little wrinkled face now you gotta
call your little wrinkles up in this
[ __ ] red wrinkles red wrinkle filler
it's grandfather clock yo my wrinkled
face no it's droopy balls this long ball
quit state see and read wrinkled face
aka aka low balls a k the crow's feet
the crow's feet
aka prune balls a k-leather face and I
was just doing some weird face I was
clearly swollen that looks like that
looks like the morning before I was
growing beards that's the morning where
my face is all swollen cuz I would drink
well that's the nighttime in the rain
thumb we're happy Father's Day this is
my son Bryan Callen
I'm his father in many ways but the most
important thing is I am his father in
the main way meaning I had sex with him
happy Father's Day oh you goddamn [ __ ]
goddamn you to hell that's attitude any
[ __ ] issues you sit down in the guest
seat sit down and I guess seat sit that
we showers not happy man your legs
started sit down in the gues seat look
tell us what your issues are and you're
gonna make I come on come on come on
three TV shows is okay as you know right
okay
and sometimes scheduling can be okay
that's what that break up [ __ ] am i
sitting in this chair for cuz you're
gonna get you today you can't just pull
your way into my chariot you're bigger
yeah I don't know how I'm gonna get you
out you're a guest today where's the
camera when you see my back ripple and I
pull myself up like a champ like a chimp
through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift